I used this strategy to break the world
record prop firm payout netting two and
a half million dollars in less than 90
days. I've been trading for 14 years and
have tested hundreds of strategies. But
if I had to start over, I'd ignore
everything other than this strategy.
Let's hop right into step one. So, step
one. Now, this is the simplest step, but
ironically most traders mess this up, so
I need you to follow this rule closely.
When you sit down for your trading
session, I want you guys to mark out
swing points. So, if you have a bullish
bias for the day, I want you to sit down
and mark out all of your hourly swing
lows leading up to that trading session.
Now, this can go back to yesterday or
even the prior day if there's not enough
data on your charts. And if you're
bearish, I want you to mark out all of
the hourly swing highs leading up to
your trading session. Now, this strategy
works on any asset and any time frame,
but just make sure that you have a
higher time frame that you're going to
use and then a lower time frame for
execution. So, in our case, we're going
to use the hourly chart as our higher
time frame. So, when I sit down in front
of my charts right at the New York
equity open, let's say I have a bullish
bias on the specific day, February 9th,
2026. I'm going to come in and just mark
out all of the hourly swing points from
the prior day. And I'm also going to
mark out this hourly swing point here as
well. Now, what I'm looking for is
obviously time of day. [music] So, I'm
waiting for the equity open and I'm
looking to see if one of these swing
lows is rated on the equity open. Now,
why are we doing that? Because we're
looking for a liquidity rate or a sweep
of liquidity. Because as most of you
already know, in order for us to
position long, we want to be able to see
sellers being trapped before the market
trades higher. I want to mention that
this step should only take you 5 to 10
minutes. Okay, you can do this across
multiple assets if you want when you sit
down in front of your charts for the
trading session. Now that you've got
your levels, it's time to frame the
trade. Now, this is what separates
unprofitable gamblers from profitable
traders. And this next step allowed me
to go from inconsistent, unprofitable to
consistently profitable. Now, the way
that most traders learn liquidity is
that once a low is swept, they're trying
to position and bottom tick the market
and try and time the reversal. But, I
added a second filter for confirmation
that not only helped me avoid losing
trades, it helped me to understand when
the market was actually going to turn
around and trade in the direction that I
expected. But, before I share that
filter, just remember that I use this
strategy to make a $2.5 million payout
at Apex Trader Funding. If you want, I
have a code that'll save you 80% off all
challenges, and I'll leave that link in
the description. Now, step two, what
we're looking for is a confirmation.
Now, what is that confirmation? What I'm
looking for is a swing failure pattern.
So, explaining this like a 5-year-old,
what we're looking for is a swing low to
be rated and a closure back above the
swing point. And vice versa, if you're
bearish, what you're looking for is the
swing high to be rated and a closure
back below. So, right now it's 9:00
a.m., let's fast forward and see what we
get at the equity open. All right, here
it's 10:00 a.m., and what do we get? We
get a swing failure pattern. So, we are
going to avoid this one because it's
ahead of the equity open. And we all
know, right at 9:30, there's some type
of manipulation. Now, we've rated out
this swing low, and we've closed back
above it. So, that is our swing failure
pattern. This is the only filter that
you guys need to add to your trading.
Because let me explain the context
behind this. The way that I'm able to be
a consistently profitable trader is
understanding context behind the market.
Each one of these candles and each one
of these movements in price action tells
us a deeper story. What this one
specific candle is telling us is that
shorts got trapped or early longs got
stopped out. Now, if you're a struggling
trader, you have to recognize are you
entering too early? Are you the one
being manipulated out of the market? Are
you the trader that's chasing the short
move right off the open? Because this
one single candle tells us that anybody
that chased short off the open is now
stuck in a losing position. And based on
this context, anybody that's in a long
position that got long below the low is
now in profit. But what we don't want to
do is try and bottom tick the market.
We're just trying to catch the meat of
the move. What we're anticipating after
the swing failure pattern is that
they're going to continue running price
higher. And all we're trying to do is
ride the coattails of smart money. Now,
you've got your levels, you've got the
context behind the trade, why you're
framing it. Now, it's time for the most
important element of trading this, the
execution. So, the importance of doing
this on a higher time frame is that
we're not going to get lost in the low
time frame noise. We want to be able to
frame a trade based off of a higher time
frame. It doesn't matter if it's the
weekly, it doesn't matter if it's the
daily, it doesn't matter if it's the
4-hour, it doesn't matter if it's the
1-hour or the 15-minute. What we're
trying to do is frame something off a
higher time frame context and framework
that actually makes sense. And then
we're only going to use a lower time
frame to get in sync with that higher
time frame idea. So, I want to ask you
guys, are you the type of trader that
sits down at your desk and is flipping
through all their time frames all of the
time? So, you're going from a 1-hour to
a 15-minute to 5-minute to 1-minute to
try and find something, and you don't
have a clear plan and process behind
your trading. I've just given you two
steps that are extremely extremely
simple to follow. You're plotting out
opposing swing points in the direction
that you're trying to trade. Step two,
you're waiting for one of the swing
points to be raided and then closing the
opposite direction. All right, no raid
means no trade. But once we have all of
those things aligned, we can now drop
down into the lower time frame, which is
what we'll do next. So, in here, let's
find an execution. And right away, I can
see that this is our 9:30 open. We have
a swing failure pattern, and as you can
see, we have a swing failure pattern on
a lower time frame. So, we can mark out
now that we have a 5-minute fair value
gap, and we're trading into that
5-minute fair value gap. Now, our lower
time frame is aligned with our higher
time frame idea. Okay, we were bullish
on the higher time frame, and we have a
bullish entry model on the lower time
frame, a 5-minute fair value gap. So,
what we're going to do is plot out a
long as it's trading into the 5-minute
fair fair gap, put our stop loss below
candle two of the fair value gap. And
let's just say we're going to target two
to one. Now, let's play this forward and
check out the result. So, we have a nice
rejection away. We're pressing towards
the highs. We have our Asian range high
up here, and we have our previous daily
high. A little bit of a retracement, and
we have another fair value gap. Now,
it's about 10:25. Let's keep playing
price forward. And there we go, our
target's hit. And just to show you guys
I actually took this trade with my
group, you can see here at 9:55 I said
hourly bullish SFP incoming. A couple
minutes later, I mentioned I was long. I
reduced my stop to 25091, which is this
previous swing point. I trailed it one
more time after rejection of this fair
value gap. And then right around 10:55,
I was trimming 50% off, and then
eventually closed out the full position.
Now, you're probably wondering that's
great, that was one example, but does
this work consistently? Now, as long as
you get the context of the market
correct, and you have a higher time
frame target, any SFP going in the
direction that you anticipate should pan
out. So, let's take a look at this
example right here on January 27th.
We're going to mark out our swing lows
ahead of the open, right? This is 8:00
a.m. leading up to the equity open. And
what we're going to do is wait for
equity open, right? Because we have this
swing failure pattern pre-market, but we
also want to wait for our session
timing. So, let's fast forward until
equity open occurs, and see which side
of the market they actually want to
raid. So, in this case, Monday was
bullish, so on Tuesday, let's assume
that this bullish trend is going to
continue. And what we're looking for is
obviously a swing low being raided. So,
I'm not going to trade this swing
failure pattern that's bearish. So, if
the market is showing strength, I want
to stay on side until the higher time
frames is telling me to go in the
opposite direction. So, in this case,
I'm only for swing lows to be raided.
So, we have this swing low, and we have
this swing low down here. And if you're
wondering what swing low do I use? Well,
it's all about timing. If we're trading
at this swing low right at the equity
open, I'm not even paying attention to
the one down here. All right, trading is
about being present and trading what's
in front of you right now. So, at 10:00
a.m., what do we have here? We have a
swing failure pattern. And this swing
failure pattern is in the direction that
we're trying to trade. As I mentioned,
Monday was very strong, we're trying to
stay in that same direction. So, now
again, this is telling us that anybody
that tried to short in the market is now
trapped and anybody that went long below
this low is sitting in profit. What
we're trying to do is just catch the
meat of the move as it trends higher for
the day. So, again, what we're going to
do is drop down to a lower time frame.
So, we have a 5-minute fair value gap
retest in here. We're going to draw out
a 5-minute fair value gap and just
anticipate on this next hour we should
see continuation. Okay, we have this
hourly close at 10:00 a.m. and we're
looking for a bullish entry model, which
we have. So, let's plot along here and
we're just going to aim for 2R again.
And let's see how this trade plays out.
We've traded into another fair value
gap, so let's say if you missed this
one, there's another opportunity in
here. And let's see if this market
continues higher. There you go, target
hit. Now, the most difficult part of
trading and what you're going to have to
manage, especially with these futures
prop firms, is that you can't hold
overnight. So, as you can see, this
trade was entered at about 10:20, but it
didn't hit our take profit until about
7:10 p.m. If you're trading a futures
prop firm and you have this idea that
the market's going to trade higher, what
you're going to need to do is manage it
around the close. So, some of these
firms might make you close at 4:00 p.m.
or 5:00 p.m. What you could do is
re-enter that trade at the rollover.
This is assuming that the market didn't
gap heavily on you because if you close
the trade at one price and let's say you
open it at the same exact price 2 hours
later or an hour later, essentially you
haven't left the trade and you have the
same amount of risk on. And I'm just
going to throw out the scenario. Let's
say you had to close the trade right
around here at 4:00 p.m. and you had a
small bit of profit. Well, if you just
enter the trade again at the rollover,
again, assuming that the market hasn't
moved, you really haven't left the
trade. But in this case, you can see
that hour period between 4:00 p.m. and
6:00 p.m., the market did trade higher
and unfortunately, you might have missed
out on this specific trade idea. But I'm
just showing you guys that this setup
does work very, very well. And if you're
trading a personal account and able to
hold this trade overnight, obviously,
you're able to benefit from this one
specific setup. So, the trickiest part
of trading in general is being
uncomfortable that these trades are very
uncertain. We don't know if the trade is
going to go directly to our take profit
during trading hours, how long it might
take, if we're going to have to suffer
drawdown. So, as you guys can see, this
trade took almost 9 hours to pan out,
but it eventually did. And it's up to
you to manage it effectively. If you're
trading prop firms and you can't hold
overnight, well, you have to manage
that. But, the key to trading this
system effectively is to have a
consistent process you follow every
single day, regardless of the outcome.
So, if part of your system is to trade
from 9:30 a.m. up to the close every
single day, yes, you may have broken
even on this trade because you were
forced to close it out ahead of the
close. But, when you sit down and
journal this trade at the end of the
day, you should still be giving yourself
an A on this specific setup because you
followed everything that you were
supposed to do. Sometimes it's going to
pan out and sometimes it's not. And
that's something you all have to become
comfortable with if you want to be a
consistently profitable trader. Did I
show up and did I follow my plan? You
now have a simple and proven approach to
liquidity. But, chances are this isn't
the only reason you still aren't
profitable. I know this because I
struggled for 10 years before I became
profitable, which is why I created the
Trading Apprentice. This is not your
average trading Discord. It is direct
access to me, a verified seven-figure
trader and world record holder, to teach
you everything I've learned in the last
14 years. I'll leave a link to apply
down in the description, but I want to
be clear, I don't work with just anyone.
If the link still works, there are slots
left. Otherwise, you can join the wait
list. And as always, thanks for
watching. Don't forget to subscribe, and
I'll see you guys in the next one.